bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
l'actu sur tv fil 78 le journal de la
rédaction nous allons faire le tour des
principales informations de ce jour en
ce lundi 24 février nous débutons par
ces jeunes majeurs sans papiers qui ont
rencontré leurs nouveaux parrains et
marraines depuis plusieurs années le
réseau éducation sans frontières des
yvelines organise cette ce type de
rencontre pour protéger les jeunes
scolarisés qui vivent sous la menace
d'une expulsion les précisions de
yolaine thorez à versailles ce lundi 17
jeunes majeurs sans papiers ont été
parrainés un événement organisé par le
réseau éducation sans frontières depuis
plusieurs années l'objectif protéger ces
jeunes en cas d'interpellation et agir
pour leur régularisation
c'est en tout cas le rôle de chaque
parent et marraines comme nicole boc
marraine d'un jeune lycéen en 1re année
de ces apps et mécanique
il peut nous appeler n'importe quand il
un détenu il ou elle à notre numéro de
téléphone et on peut aussitôt intervenir
en fonction de la nature du problème
s'il est arrêté on est là pour le
soutenir et c'est important pour eux de
savoir qu'il ya des adultes qui
s'engagent à leurs côtés lorsqu'il était
mineur la moitié de ces jeunes étaient
pris en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance mais une fois majeur il n'en
bénéficient plus et se retrouve
confronté à des difficultés
chaque jeune à 2 par an un citoyen qui
le suit et un élu pour un rôle plus
symbolique ils font les marchés où on va
m'aider pour pouvoir continuer mes
études
une dizaine d'autres majeurs seront
parrainés d'ici quelques jours
quelles stratégies pour le modem lors de
ces élections municipales dans le
département des yvelines la formation
centriste fondé par françois bayrou se
divise en fonction des villes entre
alliance avec l'ump et alliances avec le
ps le modem qui toujours dans le
département va aussi changer de
président bruno tabary en poste depuis
2011 a décidé de passer la main le porte
parole de la formation vice-président
aussi assura l'intérim il ne cache pas
ses ambitions je reçois ball au millième
bonsoir à vous bon son
venu sur ce plateau expliqué nous tout
d'abord la raison de ce changement de
présidence déjà à la raison pour
laquelle bruno tabary a décidé de vous
demander d'assurer un petit peu
l'intérim je précise que bruno tabary
est aussi candidat à plaisir lui sur une
liste socialiste on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler
voilà donc bruno bono m'a demandé de
d'assurer l'intérim puisque les
élections auront lieu au mois de juin
parce que d'abord il est très occupé par
s'attendre à un son à terme en mode
helmand oui les élections internes au
bureau du 78 donc bruno lui est très
occupé à sa campagne
vous en doutez plaisir c'est une grosse
ville moi j'ai pas je suis pas dans le
même cas
dans un tout petit village dont j'ai un
petit peu plus de temps et comme j'ai
plus de temps j'ai essayé de mettre un
petit peu au service de tous nos
candidats qui sont sur différentes
listes 87 candidats modem même signe en
vain de tête de liste ça fait beaucoup
quand même pour le département avec des
fortunes diverses
souvent ça se passe très très bien et
voilà donc j'ai proposé effectivement un
bruno quand il en a parlé sur l'intérim
sans aucun souci pour vous pouvez aider
les gens ça traduit pas un malaise au
sein du modem avec quelquefois des
alliances sur certaines listes avec le
ps quelquefois avec l'ump également chez
savait forcément vous poser ses astra
duo nationale ça se traduit aussi au
niveau mental le national dont vous
savez en ce moment il ya l'histoire
marseillaise donc ça c'est un petit peu
plus important mais nous il n'y a pas
vraiment il n'ya pas vraiment de
problème qui soutient la candidature
plutôt social voilà il n'y a pas
vraiment de problèmes sur les yvelines
si vous regardez bien aller à plus de 85
88 %
les alliances elles se font soit avec
l'ump soit avec lui dix soit avec les
deux donc de ce côté là il n'y a pas
vraiment de soucis après hésité quelques
quintes ou même à maurepas par exemple
c'est une course et une liste divers
gauche sur laquelle plutôt divers gauche
sur laquelle on trouve un candidat du
modem sur la ville de plaisir bruno
tabarez qui donc est encore le président
jusqu'au mois de juin
en tout cas vous assurer l'intérim et il
est candidat sur une liste socialiste
face à une liste ump udf
je vais vous expliquer le cas il ya
quelques cas je vais vous expliquer sa
très calmement
vous savez qu'il ya un travail municipal
qui a été fait on est en fin de
mandature il ya donc déjà six années qui
se sont écoulées
il ya des liens qui se sont tissés il ya
des projets en commun qui se sont faits
sur certaines villes et il ya des
alliances et des amitiés
c'est des histoires d'hommes aussi un
c'est ce qu'on disait
la dernière fois qu'ils se sont hissés
sur certaines villes c'est le cas à
plaisir c'est le cas villepreux aussi
par exemple ou à maurepas et ces gens là
vont sur un projet qui leur paraît
cohérent moi là dessus j'ai pas j'ai pas
grand chose à dire je si le projet leur
paraît plus cohérent que chez le copain
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la politique
politicienne et la politique deux
parties à assumer absolument les
décisions qui sont prises par le
national le national ils sont pas sur le
terrain avec nous et avec les habitants
des yvelines
donc on fait là où on pense être le
mieux le plus à même d'apporter ce qu'il
faut aux habitants des différentes
communes voilà l'an dernier une la
création de l'alliance qui regroupe
justement le modem est éludée le but
c'était de marcher main dans la main
aujourd'hui oui mais vous regardez bien
sûr les yvelines c'est le cas c'est le
cas de toute façon quand je vous dis
qu'à 3 8% après les plaisirs maurepas à
villepreux ces exemples-là sont des
exemples de travail collaboratif qui a
été fait avec ces élus là déjà depuis
très longtemps pour le bien des
habitants
donc ça n'a pas posé de problème
particulier voilà après le reste on est
vraiment dans des alliances ump udi je
vous le savez guyancourt ben on est en
alliance avec l'ump vous savez aussi que
montigny le bretonneux on va soutenir la
liste de michel laugier dollar juste
avant peut-être une précision parce que
vous parlez de montigny le bretonneux
récemment dans la presse locale on
pouvait lire qu'il y avait un candidat
du modem et rallier la liste emmenée par
la drire soir le ps ça se fait à titre
faire c'est à titre personnel alors ce
qu'on dit dans publicité n'y a pas de
souci j'ai pas de souci avec lui jean
marc oursin jean-marc on a beaucoup
discuté ensemble on aurait nous aimer au
bureau qui rejoignent la liste de michel
laugier il n'avait pas envie de le faire
ils n'avaient pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord tous les deux il a préféré
aller ailleurs il ya quoi aucun souci
c'est son choix je vais pas critiquer
les choix des candidats qu'on a
c'est leur responsabilité mais il était
bien entendu il était d'accord avec ça
qu'il y allait en son nom personnel
exclu du modem pour autant pour autant
du tout donc c'est là qu'on joue un peu
sur l'ambiguïté qui a dénoncé
aujourd'hui par jean francois hénin le
président de l'usm vraiment qualité dans
la stratégie ferais tu veux vraiment
qu'on fasse un distinguo entre les
municipales où j'ai un sondage là je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure la
préoccupation majeure des français c'est
pas le parti politique du pays d'où est
issu le candidat sauf pour les grandes
villes bien évidemment les grandes
villes ça un enjeu national
mais dans les autres villes en france
non ce qui est important pour les gens
c'est comment la commune et j'ai géré et
comment les projets sont portés et s'ils
sont réalistes
des gens ont besoin aujourd'hui de
savoir ce qui va devenir de leurs impôts
locaux
vous comme moi d'ailleurs tous autant
qu'on est
ils ont aussi besoin d'avoir de la
transparence sur la gestion municipale
et voilà tout ça c'est un porte aux gens
et les projets que les candidats vont
présenter ou que les listes vont
présenter
il faut qu'il soit réaliste et je pense
que les gens ont aussi besoin d'un petit
peu de démocratie participative je
n'aime pas beaucoup le terme mais en
tout cas d'être plus impliqué dans la
politique locale qui est plus de
sociétés civiles
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait et vous
n'êtes pas toujours tendre avec vos
alliés du moment récemment vous avez
écrit une tribune mais je vais vous
citer un entre la condescendance de
certaines têtes de liste ump à notre
égard la relative bienveillance de celle
du ps qui n'hésiteront pas un moment
revenus de nous planter un coup de
poignard dans le dos que nous reste-t-il
c'est la question que vous posez eh ben
il nous reste notre foi et notre volonté
de nous mettre au service du citoyen
c'est là vous êtes lucide sur les
alliances que vous menez avec ces
formations politiques que ce soit à
gauche ou à droite a dans certains
endroits on va voir nous nous
l'important gelé en tout cas je vous le
dis pour moi l'important c'est vraiment
qu'on ait un maximum d'élus il faut
vraiment qu'on ait un maximum des luttes
pour travailler sérieusement au service
du citoyen s'il y a des dérapages comme
on l'a toujours fait on les signalements
c'est tout c'est pas une menace je pense
que jean aujourd'hui de voir les gens
aujourd'hui envie de voir des politiques
vraiment politique au service du citoyen
et pas de la politique politicienne ce
qu'on promet on le tient on le tient
dans la transparence dans la gestion du
budget municipal qui est très important
c'est difficile en ce moment il faut pas
de dettes il faut faire attention et
bien voilà nous on est là pour ça on est
assez innovant a demandé quand même à
pas mal des jeux de deux listes de
candidats de tête de liste avec qui on
est à lier je pense que les candidats
modem dans les alliances qu'on a conclu
ont beaucoup travaillé et ont amené
beaucoup d'idées et vous arrivez
justement vous faire entendre au sein
des différentes listes qui sont qui sont
constituées d'un terme programmatique en
général oui après ça dépend ce qu'on
porte comme idée ici on n'emporte pas
beaucoup évidemment sera moins entendre
mais en général quand on porte de bonnes
idées
oui on se fait entendre aujourd'hui le
modem c'est une formation vraiment
centriste de centre-droit août
centre-gauche a alors je vais m'en
référer à une récente tribune qui a eu
dans le nouvel observateur un article
qui disait que reste-t-il du modèle
alors les gens disent évidemment le
modem bas quand bayrou en 2012 offert
son soutien à françois hollande
ils ont dit ben voilà tous les centres
droit son parti a dû d'ailleurs
maintenant que on est avec la janvier
vers le haut pour l'alliance pour
l'alliance s'est tous les centres gauche
qui sont d'abord un pas de panique c'est
pas vrai d'accord c'est comme dans tous
les partis il ya des gens qui part qu'il
ya des gens qui reviennent et on a un
taux à peu près constant de d'adhérents
donc ça ça bouge pas beaucoup
ceux qui sont partis ont été remplacées
et les gens oublient une chose il ya un
noyau dur et c'est à peu près un tiers à
tiens tiens vous regardez la répartition
du modem c'est un tiers de centre-droit
inter de centre gauche un tiers de son
triste extrémistes on va dire ça comme
ça dont je fais partie et il se tient là
il est là il est là trop dure pour vous
en tant que centriste est extrémiste
justement de télévision entre la gauche
et la droite ce qui est difficile ce qui
est difficile et vous le savez très bien
c'est de faire comprendre aux gens que
je vais pas reprendre le terme ni ni
parce que ça c'est pas bon nous ce qu'on
veut c'est travailler avec l'ouverture
la plus large possible
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui au niveau
national ça s'est vérifié dans plein de
les socialistes nous ont un peu claqué
la porte au nez ne prennent pas au
sérieux
il se trouve qu'on s'est rassemblée avec
les gens du pays et notamment avec jean
louis borloo qui a beaucoup de points
communs avec françois bayrou sur la
vision politique à la fois de la france
et surtout l'europe et il se trouve
qu'on n'est pas si mal que ça avec ces
gens là finalement il ya peu de choses
qui nous divisent nous ce qu'on veut
c'est bosser bosser bien redonner ses
lettres de noblesse à la politique
et arrêtez de polémiquer sur la
politique politicienne ça ne nous
intéresse pas bien sûr qu'il y en a au
niveau national je peux vous dire le
contraire rien à berne en département
mais nous localement mais non mais y en
a il y en a forcément il va forcément un
petit peu mais autant que faire se peut
on essaye de l'éviter et je pense que
les électeurs aux municipales jugeront
en fonction des projets en fonction des
campagnes qui seront faites et si elles
sont sincères et réaliste je suis
persuadé qu'ils feront le bon choix
merci bruno milian d'être venu en
plateau donc vice président du modem 78
vous assurez l'intérim en ce moment avec
le départ programmé de bruno est à bari
merci à vous merci
et puis pour suivre l'actualité de la
campagne des municipales rendez vous
chaque mardi à 18h30 municipales 2014
l'émission le magazine pour tout savoir
de ce qui se passe dans ce département
yvelinois et n'oubliez pas aussi les
débats que nous organisons chaque mardi
et chaque jeudi à 20 heures
l'actualité de ce 24 février c'est aussi
la nomination du vicaire général du
diocèse des yvelines olivier leborgne au
poste d'évêque damien la cérémonie
d'ordination se déroulera le 6 avril en
la cathédrale d'amiens ordonné prêtre en
1991 olivier leborgne était le bras
droit de monseigneur aumônier il a
grandi dans les yvelines il a été entre
autres responsable local et des jmj en
france en 98 il est aussi prélat
d'honneur du pape depuis 2012 une
distinction honorifique tout autre sujet
5e édition de l'élite hommes c'est le
concours international d'aéromodélisme
aux clayes-sous-bois les pilotes et
leurs maquettes qui encore proposer des
prestations spectaculaires qu'on suivait
pour nous olivier maniscalco en rogne h
nouvel envol pour l'eee top aux
clayes-sous-bois pour sa cinquième et
dernière édition la compétition
internationale d'aéromodélisme a encore
une fois réuni les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux très spectaculaire les
démonstrations de voltige ont offert un
show impressionnant
les modélistes été jugé à la fois sur
l'épreuve des figures imposées ou le
jury note la qualité technique et la
géométrie mais aussi sur du vol en
musique où les pilotes proposent un
véritable ballet aérien un pilotage
exigeant qui requiert certaines
aptitudes il faut avoir de bons réflexes
d'excellents réflexes parce que de temps
en temps mais l'avion va pas faire
exactement ce qu'il faut donc il faut
avoir des très bons réflexes
avec la télécommande
mais c'est surtout une question
d'entraînement à force de faire et puis
surtout savoir construire aussi parce
que souvent ça casse il faut savoir
reconstruire les maquettes fabriqué en
plaques de des pros et en papier millar
matériaux qui servent d'habitude à
l'isolation de nos maisons sont un peu
moins d'un mètre d'envergure pour un
poids qui varie entre 50 et 100 g des
mesures peaufiné durant la construction
des modèles réduits ou le moindre
réglage compte c'est principalement des
changements de forme sur l'avion des
des améliorations de répartition de
surface est toujours essayé de gagner du
poids parce qu'on indoor plus on est
déviée mieux ça veut la voir mon avion
on va dire sur l'analyse est assez lourd
il fait 80 g
mais il est aussi relativement grand
serre des plus grands du circuit 65
participants représentant 15
nationalités différentes concourait lors
de cet eee top 2014
six français ont terminé dans le top 10
un dernier mot de sport avec du basket
le match de la dernière chance pour les
féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles elles se sont
imposées face à rennes samedi soir et
reste donc encore en course pour ce
maintien en nationale une
quelques frayeurs cependant avec une
avance de seulement 3 points à la pause
et de deux points à quelques minutes de
la fin score final 71 64 elle reste donc
11e au général c'est la première
victoire de ses féminines de l'entente
le chesnay versailles depuis quatre mois
pour l'essentiel du sport rendez vous ce
lundi soir avec anthony rech et son 7,8
sport là que tu reviens demain à 18h sur
tv fil 78 toutes nos émissions sont à
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée